منذ خمسين عاما يجتمعوا قاده اكبر سبعه
اقتصادات في العالم سنويا قد يصعب تذكر
اسماء بعض تلك القمم اما قمه هيروشيما هذه
فستبقى محفوره في الذاكره لوقت طويل
لرمزيه المكان ولانها شكلت حدثا تاريخيا
كما وصفها رئيس الوزراء الياباني
لكن الرساله التي يواجهها فوميو كيشيدا من
مدينه تعرضت للقصف الذري ويسميها
اليابانيون مدينه السلام لا تبدو واسعه
البياض
فالصفحات الاربعون للبيان الختامي للقمه
فيها وعيد وتحذيرات غير مسبوقه تضع مجموعه
السبع على مسار تصادمي مع اثنتين من اكبر
القوى العسكريه في العالم بل والنوويه
روسيا والصين
يقول البيان ان دول السبع ملتزمه بتعزيز
دعمها الدبلوماسي والاقتصاديه والعسكري
لاوكرانيا مهما طال الزمن لزياده تكلفه
الحرب على روسيا وعلى الدول التي تقف الى
جانبها
ويبدو ان حضور الرئيس الاوكراني
اجتماعات القمه سيترجم تلك التعهدات عمليا
فللمره الاولى ستكون هناك اليه لمراقبه
وتحضير الدول التي تساعد موسكو على
الالتفاف على العقوبات الدوليه بتسويق
الثروات الروسيه من ذهب والماس ومعادن
ثمينه كما اتفق الدول السبع على دعم تسليم
اوكرانيا طائرات اف 16
وتتولى الولايات المتحده تدريب طيارها
في مارس الماضي في مدينه ساندييغو وقفنا
معا وكان معنا حينها رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك للنعل عن الالتزام
بالامن المشترك من خلال شراكتنا الثلاثيه
اوكوس لقد وقفت استراليا والولايات
المتحده معا للدفاع عن القيم المشتركه بما
في ذلك دعم الشعب الاوكراني في الدفاع عن
نفسه ضد العدوان الروسي الوحشي
حرصت اليمن وعلى ان تكون للصين حصه جيده
من البيان الختامي ايضا فطوكيو تضيق ذرعا
بازدياد النفوذ العسكري والاقتصادي
لجارتها وفي عشره بنود حذرت فيها مجموعه
السبع الصين من استخدام قوتها الاقتصاديه
سلاحا لفرض هيمنتها
وتعهدت باطلاق مبادره لمراقبه الاكراه
الاقتصادي ومساعده الدول والكيانات على
محاربته اما تايوان فيجب ان لا تحاول
بيجين تغيير الوضع القائم فيها بالقوه
وعليها ان لا تقوض الامن والاستقرار في
مضيق تايوان موقف ودعوات يؤيدها زعماء
ثمان دول دعيت لحضور قمه السبع اهمها
الهند واستراليا اللتان تشكلان مع اليابان
والولايات المتحده مجموعه الحوار الامني
الرباعي
انعقاد قمه السبع في هيروشيما يحمل رمزيه
كبيره فهي مدينه سلام تدعو لعالم خال من
الاسلحه النوويه لكن التحذيرات الشديده
اللهجه في بيان القمه ضد روسيا لحربها في
اوكرانيا والصين لضغوطها الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه اوجدت مخاوف من تحول القمه الى
نقطه انطلاق لمواجهه بين هذه القوى
العالميه فادي السينما الجزيره هيروشيما